[Music]
so now i'm going to talk about bead
based sample
cleanups so many protocols use these
magnetic beads they're known as ampure
or spry beads
and what they do is they allow you to
clean up dna without binding to a column
these can all be done
in the same tubes that you're preparing
your samples in and you use a magnetic
stand to help
move those beads to the side instead of
using a
centrifuge and these beads take
advantage of the fact that nucleic acids
can be precipitated
by polyethylene glycol a polymer and
salt
and again some of the advantages here is
that it doesn't require a column
or centrifuge to do the cleanup and so
it's really amenable to
working with multi-channel pipettes or
even liquid handlers that can handle 96
or 384 samples at a time
and the other advantage is that by
adjusting concentration of salts and
polyethylene glycol
you can actually isolate specific
sizes of nucleic acid which has
advantages
and this is based off some principles
that were discovered in the 70s
where some researchers realized that if
you alter
the concentration of peg also known as
polyethylene glycol
you can precipitate different size
fragments of dna so if you start off
with
a dna with a wide size range going from
100 bases all the way up to about 50 000
bases
if you have a high concentration of peg
you can precipitate
most of that dna and as you drop the peg
concentration you notice that
you're precipitating only the larger
fragments of dna
and these authors realize that this
could be used to take advantage
you could take advantage of this this
property to isolate specific
fragments of dna so in this example
instead of doing a few
separate reactions what they did was
they started with a
sample of dna that has a large size
range they added six percent peg
took everything that precipitated from
there and then took the supernatant that
had the smaller fragments
moved that over to a new tube added a
little bit more peg to bump up the
concentration to then 6.5 percent
took the things that precipitated and
took the super date and added some more
and during the stepwise process you can
see that they're able to isolate
specific ranges of dna and this is
really handy
for next generation sequencing library
because a lot of times we really want to
isolate dna of a certain size range
and this is a very easy way of doing
this because you don't have to deal with
any gels cutting fragments out of gels
extracting them this is all happening
kind of in solution
and it's very very useful so this method
still depended on centrifugation because
you had to
spin down and precipitate dna at the
bottom of the tube
but in the 90s a newer method using
magnetic beads
but also with these peg and sodium
chloride
solutions came about and essentially it
works this way
you have a sample that you want to
isolate nucleic acids from
you add your beet solution that contains
these magnetic beads
and peg and salt you mix it and let it
sit for a few minutes
and this causes the nucleic acids to
precipitate on the surface of these
magnetic beads
you place a tube on a magnet the beads
with nucleic acid get bound
and then move to the side and you can
remove the supernatant
and do a couple of washes and then at
the end
you can elute the dna off of the beads
just in water
and that'll cause the dna to come off of
the beads you put it back on the magnets
and then you take the supernatant that
now contains your alluded nucleic acids
and then you can move them into a new
tube and then either go onto sequencing
or the next step of your sample
preparation
and again all this doesn't require any
tubes or doesn't require any
columns or centrifuges